welcome to some sheer joy today's
episode is brought to you by gray block
pizza gray block pizza 18:11 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles gray block get
that hitter some people say he's an
archrival animus sis or a nemesis they
say some people say that he is a myth
but do myths show up in the form of man
I don't know I don't even know what I'm
talking about but I'll say this for 150
percent that we have a young man and
today fresh off this documentary about
his shoulders is popping off you know we
have a cult leader we have a film
television Instagram vine star phenom
this guy is the I mean he's the Will
Smith of vine this guy is a haberdasher
with his new babies line this guy is the
new Warren Jeffs to a lot of people he's
a comedian he's a podcaster I'm getting
tired of introducing him ladies and
gentlemen but from the congratulations
pod which I recommend you listen to if
you want to get really Dan Ted mr. Chris
D'Elia
[Music]
figure there than you are in America I
think I might be an Australian comedian
like oh yeah are you uh what's his name
arch barker i know i have arch barker
sounds also like someone vomited i feel
like that the name
yeah just saying arch barker one time I
was in Montreal and I was like coming up
and I felt like all people were starting
in on my name and Archie Barker came
down to the lobby and he was like are
you my driver no yeah and I was like
okay alright okay okay I'm one new faces
yeah I was like no this wasn't even this
was after that I have like a [ __ ] I
was like nom I'm a comedian and I
laughed and he was like oh [ __ ] okay and
then and then the next you like two
years later I saw arch barker he was at
Starbucks and he saw me he was like hey
hey Chris and I was like redemption got
a drive yeah sorry I'm parallel parked
out front
dude you look big you look older you
look I know I'm different I feel like
are you doing anything different yeah
so are you doing I kind of do take care
of yourself do you well I work out a lot
he do yeah
and because like I get I get bored on
the road but then also I just was like I
want to do action movies yeah like like
so like I'm like if I gonna do that I
have to actually do actual work you have
to look the part
ya know so I start working on really
[ __ ] hard are you doing unique types
of training because you seem like
somebody that doesn't do I see you in
some of your videos I see you you know I
know that they have the shoulder
documentary thing that people were you
know that they're missing and stuff and
I know the shoulders are outside right
now
no the the doctor the guy the crew like
oh they are I try to speed away with
their [ __ ] good drivers yeah yeah oh
it's crazy I am
well trapper ROTC - they're trying to
get pictures of people's track right and
but are you doing any like a unique
training I see you doing like American
into worse stuff when I think of you and
you're jealous a little something
jealous thoughts however if you swing in
also different the thoughts of me the
jealous thoughts of me are all about me
being active I like it out a lot yeah
now they are since you told me you
wanted to be
here right so so you have those jealous
thoughts for about 35 seconds yeah no
proviso okay yeah I don't know man like
I get like the this first of all like
this the movies that I am being
considered for are like movies TV are
like all like comedy silly you know I
mean they're a young dad or or I'm like
I've just done they're there they're
only gonna offer you stuff that you've
kind of already done right because they
can see you doing oh I'm saying is that
nearsighted by the industry well it's
just safe you know and and I don't blame
them because they know they know you
know take take an action movie star
you're gonna get offered action movie
stuff right now they're not gonna
they're not gonna you know it might be a
little bit out of the box be like well
can he do a romantic comedy I don't know
let's see him do let's see him act let's
see him audition or whatever like will
people believe it yeah exactly but first
so for me like that but I don't wanna do
this like if I'm gonna do a comedy the
best comedy for us that we're gonna do
is our stand-up right because it's more
exact what we're gonna do right you know
yeah it is interesting you start
thinking sometimes I walk I gotta fit in
in this role as a as a in a sketch or in
a series like oh I'm already doing my
whole series I know in a show and you're
me and you're also you're also if you're
gonna do a movie or a TV show you're
gonna take a pay cut because you make
more money doing stand-up so if I'm
gonna take a pay cut I want to do some
[ __ ] I want to do and to me it will be
awesome to do action or something
hilarious like that I could see you
doing in like a Deadpool but sort of
like in uh maybe like right outside like
I don't want to say Oklahoma City but
maybe like Missouri I could do a that
like Deadpool Kansas City Kansas City
like how they do the CSI in all the
different areas but they do one for they
do the Deadpool Deadpool Kansas City
yeah I think I mean I don't know I could
see you I was going are you really
unique villain and like a but like a
dark city like a Gotham yeah I
definitely have the eyebrows for that
yeah but also I'm going I think I think
what you're saying I look difficut I get
I get a little I got a little gray in
the last year oh is that what it is I
think so do see older or more confident
maybe to me you've always seemed
competent though so you couldn't seem
more confident than you have you ever
grow this out because you probably have
some Grey
yeah yeah it's very scary I have great
chest hair too oh wow
and someday they're all at the other day
on a video and it was like 70 people
said summit yeah first it hurt my
feelings didn't reminding me of my
grandfather well and that's kind of
bittersweet but also to have 70 people
talking about you're [ __ ] great Jess
here that means you made it yeah if you
have 70 people talking about your great
chest hair you made it yeah yeah well
you were the same age you know you are a
couple months younger than me I'm 39 but
that's we would say same age yeah in
life you wouldn't be like no I'm a few
months older than you because that would
be so weird yeah
like we're both 39 you wouldn't be like
no we're not the same age my birthday's
first yeah well telling old you really
are a couple days earlier yeah oh that's
I guess if somebody told me by the way
we lie you're 45 I'd be like that makes
a lot you know like your family
surprised you dinner you could be 50 you
could be 50 no no what do you think I
realize what your real age bro come on
like I'm not talking about I know you're
really just really nice for me I think
I'm running under I think I'm running in
your brain or your body though oh oh I
don't know maybe you're brainy that's
what I'm saying if somebody told me by
the way you're 43 I'd be like you know
what would be like you know that meme
that we BAE meme in the wire or is like
oh yeah that's what I would do oh that's
the [ __ ] dude it my dad was like we
lied to you you were born in 1976 hope
you like I would be like okay ah now it
makes sense
I'm glad you I'm glad you lied I would
actually be happy that my parents lied
would you be upset at them or no really
though if they're like cry 3 they had a
good reason if they were like yo the
reason is because we didn't want you to
feel like if in case we wanted you to
feel like everything you got in life you
got it you got it you know not too old
I'm saying because like I'm right now
I'm 39 and I feel very accomplished for
a 39 year old right but for a 45 year
old I feel accomplished but not very
accomplished what is the next what's
that next level we think owning a tank
nah well I'll tell you what dude
if I had I could see you getting
attacked if I had like
I mean it's because here's the thing
though first of all you can't get a tank
in LA right so you so you're not only do
you need the money for the tank you need
the money for a [ __ ] to transport the
tanker to wherever how okay you have to
get the sack you have to get an
airlifted in I would say I would keep
you know you could probably keep it you
could probably keep it somewhere [ __ ]
shitty like Albuquerque you could
probably keep it an album yeah maybe
actually probably love it if I kept the
tank there do you note I'm saying yeah
you'd have to yeah they'd be like Oh
Chris Lee keep the tank yeah yeah you
know Albuquerque the algorithm would
literally be like you know Albuquerque
is great because we have you know
whatever the crops they have and then
also Cristal he keeps his tank here yeah
spices they have spices I think yeah
they probably do cuz it's close unique
peppers
oh I remember on the news that lady got
mad at you on the news and not yeah yep
yep and you made the news bro did that
blow your mind so yeah that was like one
of the [ __ ] like a like you know what
is cool about like a career is like all
the stuff that you do like in the career
like you're like okay I want to do
stand-up special and that's all the best
[ __ ] I want to be on a TV show I want to
[ __ ] you know and I did all that I
did you know undateable I did Whitney I
did the specials come out every few
years and it's like you did the roast
chill I remember you know things like
that you're like you know what these are
the goals these are the things that I
want to do yeah and not that they're
expected but you expect them to happen
if you work very hard right like the
things like that though or like the
things that come up like you know the
the M&M thing you know like like that
[ __ ] and the Albuquerque news that [ __ ]
is the [ __ ] that's like wow really
really special and really funny because
you don't expect it to happen but it's
like the perks yeah yeah they got
[ __ ] they blasted me and then I
talked about it again and then I made
another segment they did yeah they did
it twice and did they because it seemed
like some people came to your defense
but did they did you guys reconcile it
at a certain point or no no so you would
say you have active beef yeah I will I
have active beef with Albuquerque and
I'll tell you what I'll never squash
that oh I'll never squash that beef
until I'm 30 until I'm 46 in a year 39
let's not actually make the blacks you
thinking cuz they just tuned in that I
am
46 no but uh yeah and I actually may be
spending a [ __ ] quite some time in
Albuquerque soon yeah because I might
not be serious yeah I might be actually
shooting a movie in my in Albuquerque in
is it somebody now this is a rumor that
I was heard is that it's Breaking Bad
the movie good no they are serious about
the movie but not that it's not that no
I'm not gonna be a nice guy to be in
that do you are you illegitimate we can
trust or not trust you can promise if I
tell you what I would I have never I
have never my track record is I have
never lied about Breaking Bad so far
well and I'll keep that up okay yeah
yeah yeah it's not you guys have a
[ __ ] plan here by the way there's no
Larry this is rock bottom now but it's
cool because I think I did one of the
first episodes of your old yeah do and
this is the first one is the first one
of you new one yeah it's crazy man yes
and we're out here you're gonna do like
a wall we're gonna do you know the guy
who did the cartoons of all the
different podcast people we're thinking
about getting that all around the Wallen
oh really yeah
Oh in there yeah that'd be awesome but
nobody would see that right right it
would just be for when people came in
we're gonna get like a party table maybe
in there and cool like some places where
it's crazy though this is now [ __ ]
also so far for me like you guys only
have like get a place in the [ __ ]
place yeah I mean oh yeah we're in the
thick of it but you're not you're in the
thick of it when would you stand up and
all that [ __ ] you're in the Comedy Store
and then you're [ __ ] freeze first
[ __ ] was in Marina del Rey or wherever
the [ __ ] it was and then the next [ __ ]
is all the way over [ __ ] here and
even know where we are yeah
near here I know that Encino there's a
golf course near here yeah I don't want
to say the exact location you know and
they caught a serial killer not far from
here - and Pauly Shore did a movie here
that's right he did you know
no but the Encino is actually this isn't
see no the is this actually the movie
this really was this where was this
where they shot it yeah Wow
pretty cool nice you know man um Wow
yeah dude and also you get to also work
on the mic because Jionni Paulo our
former guest from last week is here and
so he's now back on the Instagram I said
oh you guys got John and Paula
well you had to laugh Johnny you're
still working here so yeah oh wow you
guys you guys got good shoes too though
the two of you but what's up you always
wear you've been wearing those shoes
they do yeah but you can't wear a Swiss
yeah you've been where I don't do a lot
of fancy footwear yeah but that's where
you could really spice it up but you
spice it up in other ways you like you
got to Houston Jersey on yeah and a
goatee somebody made me this Rat King
oh wow that's really cool [ __ ]
awesome
yeah yeah some can't really where's
crazy shoes are given and I do the go-to
would you ever do goatee no never in my
oh I would never do a come on Dean you
know that so don't even [ __ ] if I asked
me that question yeah you know you know
what you know what that question if I
was in the different mood could start a
[ __ ] war
ya know but it's not because you know we
love each other but like that I would
never have a goatee and you know it I
would look whole I would look horrible
in a go - no you wouldn't
I would and that's what I used to think
and yeah I'm not it fits you well you
got a [ __ ] mullet - oh yeah it's like
that long hair mean your hair is almost
a molar if you cut the side you
literally is a little bit of this you
know huh cut the sides but here's you
could do I almost see you they being one
of those guys who does very your your
sideburns are half inch away from doing
magic you know that yeah hey you know
tell me anything I don't know as a
matter of fact I tell you dude I try to
shorten it up and I got the [ __ ]
thing and I try to make it shorter and
shorter and I just I always think I
always think when I do it I did it
[ __ ] two days ago I think I there we
go it's shorter and then out in the day
I'm like driving I see myself in the
thing I'm like it still looks like a
[ __ ] goddamn you know almost a
magician I don't like that yeah but I'll
never you know it's just you just gotta
shake hands with who you are sometimes
yeah yeah
and I'm almost a magician what are some
things about you if you had to change
something honestly had to change
something about crystal you're like oh
this has to go count our calf power I
would have calf power yeah yeah yeah no
I have no calf our oh my god no half
power and knee you don't have any no
dude if I even look up for a high book
on a shelf a [ __ ] you're sorry right
you got to get a water dude dude I have
no calf power and I love working out and
when it comes to calf I just I guess I
just go you know what [ __ ] I guess
forget it do it you just leave at the
end though yeah I don't I don't I save
them for the end and then
don't do that yeah yeah yeah and the
workout early dude my mom my mom would
always be like when I was a kid she
would this is the same she kind of [ __ ]
she would be like what kind of homework
do you have and I would be like oh I got
English I got math I got [ __ ] social
studies I got this and she'd be like
okay cool and then like three and then
like five o'clock would roll around like
you should get started on your homework
I'd be like you know what I [ __ ]
talked to Mike the math thing isn't due
until [ __ ] Tuesday so I don't have to
do that tonight and then turns out
social studies was a lot less than I
thought it was and she'd be like oh
really
and be like yeah okay and then nine
o'clock and she be like dude you your
homework I'd be like no but it's
actually okay and she'd be like what and
I just would never do my that's what
that's what calf exercises is like I
would never do dude I [ __ ] wish I'll
tell you what man [ __ ] dude I'll tell
you what I wish you know how they always
say like kids do your homework stay in
school I wish I didn't do more homework
I wish I did less homework really yeah
dude we do dick jokes yeah oh yeah I
don't know about walking imaginary
numbers I don't have to do any of that
work but I when I did math okay when I
was in math and I was not doing well in
math where did you sit in the classroom
oh the back until they made me setting
them and made me sit in the fall they
were like yeah it was always exactly
through like you thought the back was
the worst until you got to the front it
was like they lapped you with the front
yeah you could see it in the front end
like oh the back is this yeah and
they're like nah I'll get back in the
front like these [ __ ] I'm
lapping these people that's how about I
am so it then didn't all your friends in
the back look so dumb then once you got
to the front oh they did and yeah and
they you were even dumber but they could
only see your back
they can see your face yeah so I so I
would do math and then and then I got
like to a mat like we got two imaginary
numbers and I was like if you're just
gonna make this [ __ ] up and now on I'll
fail [ __ ] you know what I mean
like [ __ ] go [ __ ] you where's the
camera go [ __ ] yourself with your
imaginary numbers yeah and that's common
core man when I was growing up they had
yeah it got all kind of crazy carry the
one I'm like all this [ __ ] it sounds
like a fire hazard like things got real
vague and things were it sounded like
somebody's getting abduct
remember that mm-hm carry the one I'm
like I'm out of here yeah I'm not into
that
yeah I'm liking I go I go did you I go
single digits and if you want I could go
a little bit of double digits and then
that's it yeah you get into hundreds and
carry and [ __ ] and ex exponents right
[ __ ] out of here how am I here what
about a scientist yeah yeah what am i
[ __ ] burn victim do you think I want
to know how all these chemicals well I'm
just like dude you want me to do this oh
I'm like Chernobyl exploded anyway and I
don't have anything like you got guys
who do that [ __ ] me if [ __ ] out of here
that's true what are we gonna do with
that information man do you remember
learning about how like a neighborhood
worked remember that where the postman
should go in the neighborhood it was
effective so we yeah so we never learned
that my town we never learned that and I
don't think that that's a class but you
you may be may you maybe learn that that
would be amazing if there was a class on
how a neighborhood work you know what
dude there should be a [ __ ] class on
how because there's the thing there
should be these are the G should be the
classes okay for real okay I'll get out
English a little bit up to like fourth
grade yeah and then high school knowing
you don't need a English in high school
you don't need English in high school
yeah if you're here's the thing if
you're don't know English how you even
get these you're in eighth grade and you
don't know how to talk you have to you
have to join the army basically right
cuz like you know and your front line
you understand you're not the guy in the
back how the way army that's how classy
it's obviously yeah you're dumb as [ __ ]
you're in the front you know they're all
the laughter [ __ ] they impose
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you're the guy to
catch bullets with your heart yeah
exactly or a head a head or heart Johnny
caught it in the shoulder not good
enough not good enough so okay so that's
two of the classes is that English is
out right social studies by the way
that's what we learned about the knee
right what is it
yeah but but it's not though do you
understand it statues all right right
right right so this is what you should
be actually for real how a city or
neighborhood works okay okay that should
be class and we call that what just
basically Street beats all right I like
that it's a good class name also if the
class names were hip yeah
if the classes were hit like that I
would be in it man yes sir I take Street
beats doing Street beats a PAP Street B
hey Larry got a tattoo now why did Larry
get a tattoo right yeah so today we're
learning class why Larry got a tattoo
and I'm in the I'm in the front right is
it because his name is a Larry all guys
named Larry have a tattoo if you ever
met a guy who's named Larry and doesn't
have a tattoo and he's not in the Three
Stooges you have a medal Larry I'll tell
you that much so um so so you got Street
in those three beats swimming huh
mm depends really not not in Indiana Rio
but in LA yes in the west coast East
Coast you know being a beach guy yeah um
maybe like up near you know some some
[ __ ] city west of Portland you might
learn that body style or like yeah you
learn you know what you you know it's a
good what a good class would be like to
learn who an alpha is like you have to
understand who that alphas are and we
call the class Peck the pecking order
okay yeah an order like you don't you
know they go okay yeah I would who you
who do you have for P uh yeah yeah and
it would be like this real [ __ ] either
you would have teachers that were like
real alpha or these real beta
[ __ ] that were like look I
understand who I am and it's okay if
this is who you are but you need to know
who you are and if an alpha walks in the
room you kind of look at them like you
know I mean yeah that's water the plants
oh yeah yeah yeah you look at you offer
him a lollipop or whatever the [ __ ] it
is like who you know you understand you
know now class right back in order
it would be like Greg stand up show us
how you look at an alpha and if you like
because I'm a beta yes and then Greg
goes like this and you're like a plus oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah just keep hanging
the Christmas ornaments Greg right over
there another mistletoe he'll be over
there under the mistletoe a hundred
percent yeah yeah I think how to behave
at functions is another one good one
function behavior that could probably be
in pee oh yeah it could be BNP oh yeah
it could be like a cos alpha here yeah
cos alphas behave differently than betas
and oh it's different you know alphas
will leave the place early kind of to go
do something better than the other play
and we think and get there later though
the officer on the in places for like 25
minutes yeah so they barely even stroke
they get their lady and they left early
yeah would you say you're an alpha me
yeah no I think I'm more uh more of a
beta really I'm like one of this Chinese
fighting fish I think what are those
betas yeah but I think they have their
own alpha beta [ __ ] going on well I mean
yeah they're suicidal some of them you
know but they only think they're killing
them so I don't think it's a mirror in
the kiln themselves that's why they do
that
that's so [ __ ] interesting you know
what you came to a dinner once and you
came late and left early remember that
didn't really I did know you might be an
alpha yeah because you guys first of all
was a dinner in the dark oh well that's
what a [ __ ] that's what a nice place
oh you don't go to a [ __ ] bright
place for dinner do it what are you
[ __ ] you know you made some money you
gotta go for him dim the lights
yeah I want to see what nah dude that's
right you're poor in your heart you're
poor in your heart you got let that go
it's true man you are poor in your heart
you're not really okay but but that's
okay that's why people like you bro
that's one of the reasons why people
like you I like you is one reason why I
like you yeah yeah who are very
different but we also like we vibe off
each other and I'll tell you two what
was I gonna say um oh yeah you thought
you'd be all alpha by coming late and
leaving early yeah I paid for your meal
your meal so you're not gonna out alpha
me bro yeah I was like what am I gonna
do and I took what we should have
learned in school and I was like it was
like that meme with the [ __ ] who's
the guy yes that guy Phonak is doing all
the math and I was like pay for it bye
bye I got it I'll pay for and they all
went oh they did the wee babies that's a
pecking order yeah dude or you start to
live through memes you think I don't
know I did two memes Oaks and I think
that's probably yeah that's probably it
for the day probably yeah
I thought about that when I said I was
like huh too many memes jobs but what um
is what it is how was you know they
recently this guy is on trial for that
nexium cult and so I wanna see do you
see that kind of stuff in fear where the
babies and you guys could all end up so
what what's he in trouble for I haven't
heard about this he's in trouble I think
for sex trafficking and also also
produce crossing state lines they did
some other things a yeah they're getting
them for everything I mean once you go
down for sex trafficking they throw in
this [ __ ] you know they throw the
sink out with the strawberry note
- yeah so I worry about things devolving
there no the only are worried about is
uh you know the the people taking it for
what it's not for making it different
than what it actually is we live the
hedonistic lifestyle it's about [ __ ]
and sucking yeah we hang out - oh yeah
but nobody [ __ ] it sucks if you don't
want to you know I mean alright it's a
yeah yeah it's a mutual thing there's
some people surprised you know know it
you know okay cuz I saw yeah I saw a
good bit of dent merch at uh at a lot of
my shows people where to flirt with me
but yeah but to see that's to see it's
all love yeah that's the thing it's all
love right but when you got people like
people comment on my [ __ ] [ __ ] you
you're not funny at like Theo von they
don't get it you don't understand bro
this is all love yeah you know what I'm
saying yeah it's fun it's like yeah it's
like Game of Thrones a hundred percent
yeah yeah it's like you're gonna tell
you what it's not it's not Game of
Thrones yeah yeah I'm gonna season three
- don't give me this Boy month season
five oh yeah oh god how are we not doing
a recap show I don't know you know how
are we not doing a [ __ ] recap yeah hi
girlies oh yeah well that's all they
talk about really oh they're running out
of things to talk about did you know
once they once Bobby couldn't get
erections anymore they've totally drunk
with some things to talk about over
there yeah they've almost got that uh
Philippine okay they've almost got him
he's almost full time now well imagine
Bobby imagine Bobby for real like
someone was like I'm gonna kill your
family if you don't if you don't
actually do an a real style performance
singing and actually try and take it
seriously yeah you hope I'm I would die
yeah yeah because there's no way in hell
there's no way in hell Bobby could get
out in into a like a 2,000 seater and
perform for real like Frank Sinatra
songs without thinking about maybe being
funny and then pushing it a little bit
and then they would just literally slice
his fellow heads all off like Oh bro and
I'll tell you what you couldn't either
you don't think I don't think I think
you could take it seriously goddamn
that's even funny it's a good
even imagine you imagine you singing in
front of 2,000 people killing it yeah I
think honestly you could do it but it
would be so bad it'd be so bad and
here's the part though it would start to
be so bad and you would know it's bad
you would want to start to vibe on how
bad it is and you couldn't yeah yeah a
comma cannot say yes the comic yeah but
Bobby not a chance no no Bobby would not
immediately Bobby would be like I would
be like yeah what's a song like if I
could turn back the hands of time pokey
like he would do that and then they'd be
like bang bang bang bang bang his whole
lineage yeah he couldn't do it I thought
about done away over here I did I know I
know I did I was like I bet Bobby
couldn't do that
Jesus man hey have you ever have you
seen any of your babies get out of line
and you had to [ __ ] get them put them
back in the crib well yeah but I don't I
don't put them back I don't I don't I
don't call them out because I feel like
maybe they're gonna be crazy I went once
they once they you want to get lost you
want to get lost
bro in your head you're lost yeah I'm
not the guy yeah what am i I'm a
gatherer yeah no not real not a step
daddy mm-hmm you know so do you see
though that a lot that some of them are
you worried some of them might do crime
some of them doing right Jesus bro let
me let me ask a question
Wow you see this know what's just know
what's this a guy in a baby shirt was
caught on camera
he took a package off someone's holy
[Laughter]
where I gotta had no idea these guys are
both big fans eaters way bigger fans in
their mind they've never bring up
shopping very fast
I saw this on Twitter and I can we see
more about this one boo God it says does
anybody know these men they stole two
packages from my neighbor and it's a
screenshot of a security cam oh dude
clear as day you can see baby this is
hilarious and oddly the what colors just
like yeah that's Nick which is very
interesting you didn't know this though
yeah this is oh yes turn it down one
man that's funny as [ __ ] well you had no
idea so this guy did some crime and he's
a babies
he's a hazing so that's the thing like I
don't want him doing that what but I
can't the number one reply was a quote
from you it said people in this cult
have literally killed people I'm just
gonna say that to you and that's not
doesn't say to you like you think like
take about you did the last show in
Brisbane 3,000 people yeah you think
none of those guys you think none of
those guys killed anybody
that's just too many people yeah in
Australia maybe in Australia they didn't
if you did it show 2,000 people in
America [ __ ] seven people have killed
people
yeah what I'm saying oh yeah I remember
when I was exact we don't do background
checks yeah it's not in my call it's
yeah I remember when I was young and
they had class and they said that um you
are walked into class statistics the guy
said there was seven hundred people in
class he said statistically speaking to
you guys will be registered sex
offenders was like one of the first
thing Jesus where did you go to school
Louisiana State yeah Louisiana that's
the man I remember that's when I stood
up and yelled not it that's what I
remember I yelled rushed bro do I do
that yeah wow dude Wow um and wait was
that freshman year yeah that's for
senior Wow so that was your whole
[ __ ] you were the funny guy
immediately then yeah there was nobody
[ __ ] that guy either man wow that got
jerked himself off often though at the
house do you masturbate at your age or
did you do it more when you were younger
what is that what's that journey been
like for you um I don't know I don't
really I don't really do it too much I
do it more on the road yeah you know but
are you are you what what what I feel
like I know what dude you jerk off a lot
when you were younger
oh yeah yeah the 20 that in over in
Santa Monica yeah I've come in that area
brother not proud of it yeah get away
from me but there's a porn place right
across the hall now so feos gonna what
do you mean though it's there like an
agency oh wow Wow right across the
session you want em presentative no huh
um so wait well I was gonna say hold on
there was a thing about about about
jerking off yeah I'm try not to jerk off
anymore now cool yeah well yeah Europe
wanna know
guy that would be like you know what I'm
gonna try to not jerk off why why cuz he
just makes me feel weak or makes me feel
sad if I drag off why I don't know why
it's a good question but it makes me a
lot of people feel that way really
immediately it makes me feel that by it
makes me feel ashamed of myself so weird
to me yeah I mean you know understand
yeah yeah yeah that's bad thing but ya
know I don't think y'all think you're
just discussing about yeah man I just
feel if I jerk off to Mike [ __ ] man you
know why such a [ __ ] loser I don't
know why that's but it's a real thing
but it's just like eating yeah
it's not like eating it's like barfing I
feel like out of your Weiner yeah yeah
yeah so it's like yeah both of them but
like in a way it's like both of those I
get to barfing out of your wiener but
it's also you just do it I think if I
injected it back into my body you'd feel
a lot better yeah that's something about
like losing my esteem losing my manhood
losing my much cheese mo yeah that's
very a very ancient of you is it you
think you're a very ancient like you're
like you should be in like Grecian old
like you know really you think I seem
ancient I would be on stage I think no I
think the when you come you feel ancient
is [ __ ] afterwards but I think that you
I think that you here's a deal you know
in like Greece like however many years
ago thousands of years ago or [ __ ]
however many years ago they would be
like we have to [ __ ] these boys to make
them men yeah yeah you know about that
yeah I've seen it
you seem like you have heard about it
yeah so if I was transported back into
that time and they said hey this is how
we do it you have to do it I would be
like okay I'm not gonna do that and I
think it would be [ __ ] so many years
before I cracked I think for you will be
eight days really yeah you think I think
you like I don't know and they'd be like
this is what we do and you'd be like no
and a week would go by and you'd be like
I guess I gotta fit in oh and you eight
or nine days you'd be like if this is
how they do the manhood thing and what
I'll do after that you feel real bad but
like in their coming weeks and months
and years what happens to me well you
probably I mean you know you know you
probably just become grecian and you're
[ __ ] that guy I don't do that hmm
yeah that makes me said yeah I would
hate that they don't hate to be [ __ ]
some guy from a long time ago yeah
yeah I would imagine that like it's hard
enough probably banging some guy you
don't even want to [ __ ] these days you
know but imagine a thousand years ago
banging dude when people are like you
know people think it's magic people
don't know what it is yeah and I also
tell you that they were not clean oh
they were so dirty they were just
outside a lot more you know all the hair
on them yeah you know yeah don't make
that sound that's one of the worst
sounds you'll make yeah my freaking
grandfather he's always made yeah yeah
yeah yeah you think when you're old you
give a [ __ ] anymore you don't you're
[ __ ] nothing it cannot and nothing
get you fired up anymore you think when
you're older uh I think yeah and I can't
wait for that really yeah yeah I it I
can't wait for that dude I already feel
like like like I don't want to do so
much [ __ ] like there's like three things
I like doing you know and and sometimes
jerking off and coming is one of them so
don't take that from me don't get it
yeah don't try to don't try to like be
like I feel bad yeah you're right I wish
I did it man I wish it was awesome like
I just got everything more like I'm
gonna [ __ ] jerk off real quicker than
they enjoy the rest of my experience
today it's just not for me question do
you and I don't even really like talk
about this but do you do you take your
time doing it or do you just do it to
get it done hmm I usually I can get it
done in less than a minute I'll never
take more than two minutes but that
might be one of your problems you think
so
take yourself on under the date bro yeah
yeah you know like go out to dinner you
do something nice you know what I mean
go to like [ __ ] pizza Cucina or some
nice [ __ ] I don't even know if that's a
place but like that would sound like
that and go go to like a hardy said as
an upstairs yeah yeah yeah yeah 100% be
like yeah we're they you're like are you
guys heating up there yeah and I'd be
like I'm on a nice date there I got once
you sit there you drink some wine or
don't forget or drink but like you get
some club soda
yeah and just [ __ ] you have a
conversation with yourself you know it's
like not out loud but in your head and
then you go home and you're [ __ ]
thinking like you know that was nice
yeah
and if there was somebody there you
would be like that was very nice wasn't
it they'd be like it was nice yeah have
a good time dude shake hands with who
the [ __ ] you are bro go home turn on
some Netflix maybe watch [ __ ] always
be my baby
and then afterwards or in the middle you
know what I mean cuz you know when
you're watching the Netflix in the girl
is it or do you keep now you keep it
going oh no you don't though think about
it think about if you're with a chick
you don't pause it pause it Allah knows
yeah that's a boss move wow you're an
alpha mi you're watching a movie with a
chick you're watching you just go boom
yeah that's amazing bro I don't pause it
um you know why I'm too scared okay yeah
bro you keep it going you go like well
[Music]
you gotta pause it man you way already
watched 11 [ __ ] 12 minutes I know
because you want to keep it what you see
that's actually a good move because then
it's like you're like I'm pausing this
because I want to kiss you but just so
you know I want to get back to this
movie our words are not that important
for me to miss this movie who knows but
you know what I've thought what I've
been working on a lot lately is a lot is
when I when I'm staring at somebody and
then they look at me you know the the
instinct is to look away but that's a
[ __ ] move you gotta keep staring at
them if they're if you're staring at
them and they catch you you're like this
is what I was doing and I'm not stopping
because you chose to live your life well
that is something you got to do that
I've been working on that is very hard
for some reason is now yes because it's
extremely unnatural I know it's very
unnatural but I think that we can switch
that I think we changed up I think we
can change that I want this is because
here's the thing I want my kids to
[ __ ] do that right so I have to work
on it for myself and this way when
they're growing up and they see me in
the front yard just looking at the
papers yeah I can't wait I actually
can't wait the neighbors out there
picking up [ __ ] look like a [ __ ]
serial killer what's the [ __ ] is wrong
with those kids and then I and then I
and then I call them and they go hello
and I say nothing click nothing's wrong
with them there's how I designed my kids
bro if I could build kids that would be
amazing
build
my kids yeah you know how you can like
customize Nike if they had kid ID or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah I would do that
[ __ ] on a website click click I want his
arms a little shorter his legs a little
longer camouflage elbows what else would
you do yeah what I would make him look
you know what I would do I would make
him whatever it is I would make him look
real bad in like any kind of like
stupidest [ __ ] outfit I would make sure
he has the body only to wear normal
[ __ ] clothes because I don't want him
getting [ __ ] artsy right I mean for I
don't want him being like like I saw a
guy the other day in a skirt but not
because he identified as a woman or was
gay just because he thought it was cool
my son's not doing that [ __ ] I said Jay
if you identify as girl fine that's fine
wear the skirt if you're gay wear the
skirt but don't be the guy that's like
this looks good on me and I [ __ ]
checks yeah no yeah Jane Smith dresses
like a Scottish man like yeah what
Scottish man yeah today's episode is
brought to you by Ridge wallet a lot of
people you know might have a wallet
someone might not
some people are deceased but the thing
about the ridge wallet is it's something
you put in the front pocket no more this
back fancy pants you know your butt is
all obscure oh look at that guy look at
the growth oh he must have measles or
mumps look at that hump on net boy
things are different now now you can get
that front pocket carry from Ridge it's
that front pocket wallet go to Ridge
wallet dot-com slash tpw and use code
tpw at checkout for 10% off that
beautiful Ridge wallet do you have a lot
of fancy wallets well time for something
new something novel I'm talking about
that front pocket carry concise
concealable ooh he's got that action
that's code tpw for 10% off at Ridge
wallet dot-com /tp W enjoy that front
pocket carry this past weekend is
brought to you by Skillshare sometimes
you think you know a skill and then you
get out in the world and you don't
sometimes people say oh you could do
cement you get out there about a mixer
and you got the rake and the shovel and
then you uni doing [ __ ] you know but
things can change and Skillshare is here
to help Skillshare an online learning
community for creative creators with
more than 25,000 classes in business
design and more you'll discover
countless ways to fuel your curiosity
creativity and your career take classes
in social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing even
illustration I'm on there right now on
Skillshare
trying to find ways that I can more fine
tune things that I do on social media
whether you're looking to discover a new
passion or start that sad hustle gain
skills anyway go to Skillshare it's
there to keep you learning and reaching
new goals join the millions of students
I'm talking millions already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
get two months of Skillshare for free
that's right skills share is offering
this past weekend listeners two months
of unlimited access for over 25,000
classes for free go to Skillshare
dot-com / Theo von again go to
Skillshare dot-com / Theo von to get
your 2 months started now Skillshare com
/ Theo von and thank you so much for
supporting this past weekend yeah I
could see also I could see would be cool
if your kids were immediately the same
height as you like once I hit like nine
years / 11 that would probably be an
advanced package you'd have to buy yeah
can you imagine ooh some 11-year old
same height you know I would do weaker
neck and arms the [ __ ] calf power I'd
have my kid have a calf power because I
got a 20-person you know like yeah I'm
20 yeah yeah [ __ ] man and look at the
calf's in that guy brown eyes not blue
eyes no way have you ever met a guy with
blue eyes or blue eyes no I don't have
blue eyes dude look at me I'm live feet
away from you you got like brown or
green eyes yes yeah I would never trust
a guy with blue eyes
just hand hands down you know it's just
as America to have blue eyes as a guy
yeah yeah you don't think so also blonde
hair you're pushing it
yeah you don't have blond hair as a guy
a guy with blond hair no a guy was
blonde hair blue eyes no way yeah cuz
here's the thing you got to look good in
a [ __ ] black leather jacket as a dude
and then if you have blond hair you
don't you got to wear a brown leather
jacket ooh
violent legs and my mom wears but but
but it's okay to wear a brown leather
jacket sometimes if you're a blonde guy
you gotta wear it all the time and
that's not okay I don't know yeah well I
do and that's how much I'm thinking
about this [ __ ] yeah that's crazy matter
so do you have do you do you where do
your I do you think ideas just come into
your head or where are they what are you
always just like thinking of something
yeah like you see something you like I'm
gonna think about this yeah I think
about it all the time I don't think
about the [ __ ] that matters yeah you
don't know I [ __ ] just worry about
the [ __ ] that matters yeah but you also
have that [ __ ] thing where it's like
I wonder what Bobbie looked like we were
different lips like yeah think about
that yeah I just want I mean I think
about Bobbie a lot dude cuz I worry that
he's just not living up to his full
potential right so you think about that
which is very nice but also you might
think you know what it's like inside of
his girl no but your make up [ __ ] you
make don't you make up situations in
your head I do it all no you do this oh
yeah I think I used to be able to do it
more and I don't know what happening is
I got older I got more worried oh [ __ ] I
mean that's what my podcast is is what
if this happened and then that happened
and if for some reason people listen to
it yeah you're good at that man you're
good at being like what
[Applause]
yeah and then like taking us in like an
alternate universe but it's good I think
it's what makes you a good actor it's
like you have an interest in taking
people into an alternate universe you
know it's nothing it's one of the thing
that maybe make you want to be a fighter
like a superhero or or uh you know in
that universe is because you want to be
in these alternate universes you want to
be able to shoot a laser out of your
[ __ ] neck bone you know like you want
to be able to lift it up into a [ __ ]
galaxy ship you know yeah I think these
are things that you know that seem
realistic on you because you you you've
kind of fan it you you kind of live them
out of here every day even your some of
your old images I remember on your
website you're on a [ __ ] you're
shooting [ __ ] my water gun on top of
a [ __ ] to shoot whales back or
something like where is this
[ __ ] dude is he must be you know
by the airport or something you can't
check yourself though you know that's
the thing like you and you're good at
that but you also do you check yourself
sometimes yeah I think I check myself
often yeah but you're you're you but you
also dump you but you also is what makes
you so [ __ ] funny it's like you have
your own language and [ __ ] like what we
actually kind of both have that like you
don't I mean like people do in your
terms and [ __ ] but like you uh you uh
you like your you have a style where
like you're so you and that's because
you let yourself be that way yeah that's
when you're best I think yeah I think
that's what most people thing about you
you know and then like you go off and
you worry about stuff after that yeah
that's what I did
immediately when I get off yeah you
don't have to do the first I see if Neal
Brennan has any advice for me and then I
just go worry about myself and he does
and he does yeah he usually has a couple
of [ __ ] free inside what about this
so dude do you think that um do you find
I I find sometimes I have trouble
telling a story that I've told before
after a while on the road and making it
a genuine to myself interesting well
you're like a storyteller pretty much
right yes I think so yeah I mean I like
tell us no yeah no I mean you're [ __ ]
that you did you should right you kind
of are though yeah kind of yeah kind of
um it's yes sometimes it's weird like
like I'll do a bit like five times
and it'll crush and then it'll drop off
that's like five times and then I'll get
it back for a while and then like after
like
seven months that I think that's what
you're talking about like I'll just be
like I'm just doing this I'm just saying
yes that's what it used to be and I
can't find my way out of that it's like
every time I'm like okay I'm gonna make
it freshest I'm gonna make it new and
I'll try to but it just doesn't but a
newer bit always does better I know I
know I know and it's kind of sucks too
because like a bit is so much better
like you ever do like the other day I
did some [ __ ] that I've been doing then
I did a new bit and it worked and it was
good it wasn't amazing but it was good
and then I went into my old [ __ ] like
that I again like from that I've been
working on and it was just like oh
that's how a bit works it was like boom
boom boom boom boom boom and I was like
[ __ ] I gotta get that new bit to that
right but the new bit is the [ __ ] the
the laughs that you're getting from the
new bit are this is the [ __ ] that where
they're like they they're laughing
because they feel you excited about it
you know yeah oh maybe that's what it is
and they they can understand you're
excite you so I always like think about
like like oh I laugh a lot on stage yeah
people are like are you laughing is that
real and the truth is I'm laughing not
at what I'm saying I'm laughing at the
fact that I can't believe I get to do
this for a job right and it's so fun and
I'm like looking at you guys and like
you think this is funny like I'm already
there right now like I'm like this is
[ __ ] awesome and that's why I'm
laughing like I can't believe you let me
do this as a job and these jokes that I
thought of a lot of them I thought of on
stage so I laughed when I was saying
them so I just keep that vibe you know
yeah it's not like I'm laughing I know
I've said this [ __ ] before you know
right but there's a genuine laugh you
know yeah it's fun to see it's fun and
know that people are gonna enjoy stuff
yeah yeah knowing that they're gonna
about to enjoy it or that they are
having a good time it's like yeah it's
fun yeah I feel like it's an audience
member like you see the spark and the
comedian and they're enjoying it yeah
that's my yeah and I think that's what
really is like they're so like in touch
with this and then after a while like
obviously you're doing the same joke
it's like you're not as excited telling
the story so the crowd isn't excited
yeah I mean it's definitely like an
energy thing right yeah yeah it must be
and you must be yeah that's why some of
this not like I want to tell them the
story cuz they've never heard it but I
just it doesn't land as great as it once
did but you know what though sometimes
it does and you just don't think it does
you know like you ever have those sets
where you're like oh they didn't like me
and then they come out like if there's a
meeting great and they're like dude does
the funniest thing I've ever seen
yeah you're like a Minnesota yeah yeah
you didn't seem like it yeah alright
yeah I guess that's true and I guess
maybe you hear the same if you hear a
song enough if you know the cadences of
their laughter a certain point you hear
so it's like hearing a song enough we're
like oh the song is still good but it's
not the same as this new song that I'm
right yeah when I tell these new jokes
and I get different I have song like
remember the time the first time you
heard [ __ ] ha n it's so hot in here
you were like oh what yeah that [ __ ]
Nelly song bang bang yes so good but now
you'd be like okay well maybe now you'd
be like oh I remember that but like
after like here's the thing good songs
like four years later you're like get
this [ __ ] off yeah but songs like eight
years later yeah you're like oh this
[ __ ] Rock yeah we did that you got to
get back to that point in your act you
know at least for me I think like I'll
do the song I'll do the joke it's
banging because it's a hit it's a new
song that just came out and then it
drops off because it's like you're in
the three year thing where you're like
oh this is like an old song yeah and
then it's like when I was when I was
young when I was fifteen and sixteen I
started get embarrassed hanging out with
my dad because that's like the age you
get embarrassed oh yeah yeah yeah my dad
said we used to hang out what the [ __ ]
and I said to him yeah but it only lasts
for like a few years when I'm 19 or 20
after high school again it'll be cool to
hang out with you again he was like
really anyway I was like yep and it's
true wow this is out is that it's that
thing you got back to being a 19 year
old again was cool hanging out your dad
know who's at an advanced until yeah
yeah my dad always brings it up he was
like dude how did you know that in
advance and I was like I don't know I
think I just saw people doing it do you
know all of it like all the beats of the
life and then it's just like you are you
think so so how are you enjoying it then
if you already know it all if you like
know that how it's all gonna kind of
break down and when to do what
yeah but it's like it's like because
the anticipation is what the most fun
which is the which is the fun it's like
when you're like you're like let's go to
Vegas and you're in Vegas it's usually
not as fun as the whole [ __ ] let's go
to Vegas right yeah they're the on the
way there is the best part because
you're thinking about [ __ ] yeah
let's do it yeah isn't it do you think
you could be ever fall victim to a
surprise party or not I have you have
yeah Wow yeah it was [ __ ] it was it
no it was great
but it's [ __ ] that they got me
really yeah yeah cuz you seem like the
kind of guy who would not let people get
him on a surprise party it's your
[ __ ] birthday you know I mean it's
she got me it was [ __ ] mm it was 2007
Wow six she [ __ ] got me man what was
it a restaurant it was at a bar there
was a bar restaurant yeah well I don't
think a place exists anymore I think
after that meant they shut down hey yeah
yeah we gotta believe they got me oh
yeah I don't think that I will be able
to get gone now really yeah
easy way to like you seem like the
coming guy who like as somebody's
walking into a restaurant with like hey
it's just know it's a surprise party get
in there don't let them yeah I would be
like I'm even now like my birthday's in
March but when somebody's like you want
to hang out and it's September I'm like
but not for my birthday yeah we got some
questions that came in for crystally
let's see him went your new film coming
out Chris I don't know I think in the
fall but I'm not sure are you excited
about it are you nervous about it nah
I'm yeah whatever it's fine you know you
but it went well yeah yeah I'm good I'm
happy like you know who honestly
whatever nothing matters anyway yeah for
real like you know it's like yeah we
should like not it's true though you
know how it's like people are like ah is
it okay if I do this [ __ ] spot for
Comedy Central or is okay if I do this
movie it doesn't matter do it yeah it
doesn't matter yeah unless it's like a
[ __ ] we heard her yeah or like
Captain America yeah if you had to fight
for a country would it be America like
as a superhero would it be I think I
would be like
you know I don't think I don't think I
would pick a country I think I would
just be like look we're gonna be in this
all together you know this is from this
is for this is for the better of mankind
you know mm-hmm do you think you could
save the world like from what though I
don't know probably not but damn but you
would try wouldn't you uh uh yeah I
would try yeah I would try it yeah try
but like I love this this is the
character I already loved this character
sky and I'll be this superhero a doctor
maybe I would try yeah yeah I would try
but like it will be tough for me that
should be the pitch taper whatever the
[ __ ] film is gonna be it look it I'm
gonna tell you guys the true yeah it's
gonna be tough look I know we got this
sidekick over here [ __ ] water man or
whatever your name is
yeah I don't know guy this is what are
we up against and then they show me and
I'm like I'm not gonna lie dude it's
gonna be it's gonna be tough and I don't
know if I can do it but I'll do it I'll
try realism that's your [ __ ] that's
your superhero name yeah
realism I'm gonna need a bunch of rocks
and watch my guns yeah and you're gonna
need to get a divorce you tell what you
guys yeah yeah and here's the other
thing too the rocks can't be too heavy
they have to be carry about so yeah
that's we're at guys let's hit a
question here what do we have Nick you
want to turn up one again cuz it's gonna
come out of those headphones you need
headphones on I know what up deal what
up Chris
it's Brian from Ohio Akron Ohio what's
up had a quick question was just curious
as to how you guys met each other yes
and what were the first impressions did
you guys like each other did you not you
know let me know Gang Gang okay
blue eyed first of all that yeah he
cannot get with a brown leather jacket
on
so you're crossing guards crossing guard
presenting I mean that's hopefully was
yeah I know that you're a crossing guard
of close oh oh yeah oh yeah for sure
look I that guy could be standing naked
and you'd be like oh you love golf yeah
that's true but he also say either is a
crossing guard he's valedictorian at
[ __ ] a footlocker cuz that's some
very neon green sash yeah we know what
we know what we know one one thing that
he for sure is what one two three a
Republican yeah two-term Truong saying
yeah he has a little tattered and that's
okay you know you everybody makes their
own choices get in the booth and vote
yeah so uh so the question yeah I know
what I got you really yep do you it's
hard to remember your money I hate this
because if you don't remember then the
other person can [ __ ] trump you and
just not believe what they say there's
no reason why you'd remember when we've
had our first conversation there's zero
reason why you'd remember and I know and
I know this okay and you don't even know
when it was and it wasn't and both of us
were not doing stand-up yet really up
and I've told you this and you forgot it
because of the same reason why when I
told you this was the same reason why
when we met is because you were high
both times
really that's awesome we were in we were
in a saddle ranch no were you doing
there you know what I don't know okay
yeah me neither yeah so so you the
people were riding the bull and you were
kind of like you were with some people
that had to do with some kind of
production I think it was that but you I
was not in line for the books I would
not ever ride the bull right you we were
all around that area and I was like huh
and I looked at you I was like crazy huh
or something I don't know what I said
but you said and a lot of chicks out
there out we're in a world in the bowl
yeah
you see all these girls huh something
like that yeah and you were so faded
yeah like I'm pills or something
[ __ ] you were on pills this isn't a real
thing or something
it was sound rants brother I'm a member
you had a hat on dude I remember
dude I remember when I met you then no I
didn't make it up yeah you can't say
then after that that's a real story
I do remember all right I remember when
I met you so I remember I was playing
like a young Trey athletic men's
basketball league right already this is
wrong no L didn't used to live near
Olympic this is off of Olympic Boulevard
no era was it couldn't it might have
been might have enough somewhere else
I'll go Wilshire or Senate or Santa
Monica Boulevard and um and it was like
it was a like a it was like a league I
was in as like a championship game or
whatever my team was our team was called
hot to trot right that was our team okay
so anyway when he's coming back to me
now
yeah so anyway it's like the end of the
game I Drive get fouled score right it's
an obvious and one I'm gonna go to the
line and the ref bro okay first of all
the [ __ ] crap dude all legs right
this is probably 10 years ago and you
were a little bit younger okay
all legs do barely it was like legs and
like long hair and you couldn't really
know much else about him um he's like no
foul that's what he said blues whistling
comes over and goes no foul it was you
and he was on pills
I don't know fuse on pills but he
definitely he didn't know anything about
refereeing I don't even know people was
an actual referee but I just remember
him he [ __ ] ruined it Wow and I
discern a man for who the [ __ ] is that
guy how do you get attention I don't I
tell you what there's a lot [ __ ] my life
I don't remember I don't remember that
but I will tell you this I stand by my
call it that yeah and I I honestly think
you [ __ ] traveled to by my mom yeah I
think you probably traveled dude it was
for the west district city championship
bro and I was like and I think I
remember if I don't remember this what
if it did happen I think I remember
thinking do it I wonder if he [ __ ]
paid for a plane ticket with that travel
oh yeah yeah well like I got a shower
from kayak yeah yeah I remember the guys
had a really bad joke like that
were you on pricing calm or whatever the
[ __ ] and you go wha and I saw on your
face in the middle of the
what you got the joke yeah but yeah I
definitely remember that man or so do
you remember a meeting I don't remember
the first time we met comedy wise though
stand up beside outside of the saddle
ranch or the basketball rec league yeah
I don't remember I mean I remember one
night there was some girl that got mad
at you on the front porch of the
comments remember that and I remember
like she was just being like a real
[ __ ] and I remember I don't remember
that
the only other times of it that I even I
don't even remember talking to you that
much until maybe about like two years
ago mmm you know hmm I never liked
talking to people that were doing well
in comedy yeah I know you're [ __ ]
weird like that bro well because I don't
like them I never won I don't know so
many people that seem like we're like
yeah I understand that but you're so not
that guy yeah but if you do that kind of
behavior then I think you become that
guy so you're aware of that then you're
not gonna be that guy right you know
it's not like you're [ __ ] you know
it's not like you're like the guy that's
like these [ __ ] guys around you know
as it just stand yeah you're like what
what are you doing model standing yeah
but you like in the parking lot of the
Comedy Store you're talking and you're
like what's but what's [ __ ] going on
here oh there's a guy right here oh yeah
those guys yeah we're like you're like
am I in a horror movie what the [ __ ] is
happening you yeah and there's just a
[ __ ] never wearing stander if I was
ever a stander dude and [ __ ] dude get
out of here there's gonna slaughter at
least pace yeah a hundred percent and if
you're just gonna stand say some [ __ ]
yeah those guys got to go go to lunch
those guys are [ __ ] out to lunch go
to lunch right this one I would press
one of your buttons right now but I'm
using this right um let's get another
question that came in but I don't
remember I do remember being I felt like
intimidated to talk to you kind of I
would get nervous towering cuz you were
always so confident you always say that
yeah yeah and I was I remember I'd be
like I don't know what I'm gonna [ __ ]
say like
you know my go over there I'll here's
the guy this is like if me and you had a
baby I just got hey guys I'm Yours
Austin from Jackson Mississippi course
we're so excited you guys are doing a
podcast together gang gang cult cult
anyways ask Chris if he's gonna continue
with the 30 minute stand-up specials or
if he's gonna go back to the traditional
our love to hear your thoughts on that
or just go ready player nice guy to
Jackson Mississippi Mike over there over
there by Hal and Mal's and I think
Cherokee bar once you cross the line
you're drunk
yeah weird oh yeah you see the sign
welcome to Jackson Mississippi my
reading goes down the second IV you know
it's interesting so yeah so what would
you do next would you do another
necklace where you put something out in
your own you do so I'm doing another
special yeah for Netflix and it'll be an
hour I I'm shooting it soon but I the
next few months but I the this the half
hour thing I they came to me with and
they were like do you want to do it and
I just thought it was a cool idea
because first of all I had a half an
hour material that I didn't want to put
on my next special so I was like that's
perfect for me and also like I'm I'm
always I always want to try the new
thing or the different thing I at least
want to try it like I want to like like
I I think I think a lot of people so my
two other specials on Netflix
incorrigible and man on fire man on fire
is 60 minutes incorrigible ISM an hour
and 20 minutes or 15 minutes something
like that I know that so my first one on
Netflix incorrigible I purposely put the
Banger [ __ ] at the end because you close
with the Banger [ __ ] you know I mean but
I know people didn't get to that because
that's a long time to watch stand-up and
people watch it before they're gonna go
out at night or they're just they you
know they put it on at night and they
fall as happy if yet it's very will
watch passively exactly so I know
because of that they often reference the
first half of that incorrigible man and
I'm like I know the second half is way
funnier they say oh I love the part
about
like you don't watch the whole thing
right because the list right better no
one ever talks about the end stuff
exactly
so with man on fire it's a little
different cuz it's a half a it's an it's
an hour and so I started thinking like I
think people are just trying to consume
[ __ ] I think that it's better to click
on so I think well it's only a half hour
I'll watch it right I got time so I was
like I really want to do that because I
think that'll be a good idea and I had
the material but you know some people
were like I think they thought they're
being slick they were like oh dude so
you they were not allowing you to do an
hour it's like yeah I just get the
business but like yeah I'm doing my name
is Nick Swardson did I mean it was a
cool group - it was Neal it wasn't cool
so um yeah I don't know I also thought
it'd be good for my like overseas shed
because it's like the world thing that
they were doing the yeah a means of the
world yeah so I'm gonna do another hour
I have it ready pretty much and I'm
cutting and pasting but yeah Wow well by
the way what about you what are you
doing you don't know yeah I don't know
yeah yeah I mean I think uh yeah I mean
I'm ready to do one no yeah yeah
definitely I just don't know what to do
yeah Conde well just play it right you
know take your time like you don't I
mean not take your time but like hold
out you know I mean like honestly dude
even like what what like Andrew Schultz
is doing is [ __ ] cool like he's just
putting it out as it you know every now
and then on YouTube like yeah kind of
like that the only thing is there's no
like payday no money but but but but you
own it's in the best it's an investment
though it's like you know it's like you
know you you you you build up the views
you build up the fanbase which which
you've already done with your podcast
and [ __ ] but like you know when people
love you definitely special but it's
just like you know yeah I mean my
Netflix post was kind of [ __ ] I'd like
to have another one on there that was
pretty cool I mean I would even see if
maybe you don't like it you don't like I
didn't like the first yeah but maybe
it's just because it's [ __ ] you and
you yeah it was just a bed that that
week in the show's was just rough oh
really it just wasn't haunted that good
of an experience
I mean I'm grateful for it it was fun
and and it was what it was you know is I
will never know what kind of crowd or
what kind of vibe we're gonna get Yeah
right yeah um so that was kind of tricky
you know um let's take another question
or two all right since we like this guy
we got another quest
from your son Sofia
it's Austin Eubanks Jackson Mississippi
just get my oil change my question for
daddy is what's your role gonna be at
the log cabin this Thea at the log cabin
as he reached elder status oh yeah
is he gonna be rolling honestly think
that's Charlie Rangel okay so uh yeah
everyone's invited if you want to be a
part of that feel like what I do be a
part of the cult is like you're asking
the question you're already in it you
know that's what we say here so you took
the first step thank you very much so
that's cool yeah they say they say what
do I have to do to be in the call I say
you're welcome that's a few sentences I
say no that's how it goes here and see
yeah so you know look it's my call but
it doesn't mean that [ __ ] you know
okay you know if I say you know guys
this [ __ ] [ __ ] we need this to be you
know whatever it is done then you know
somebody's gotta do it but there's
enough people that's something I'll do
it somebody will do it yeah you see you
see you see Chernobyl that show oh yeah
really good but the guys are like we
need [ __ ] three of you to go in and
turn the water off and you're all gonna
die in the next week and they didn't do
it and and everyone's like and then some
guy finally was like all right I'll do
it it's like if something's gonna do
that so [ __ ] bad analogue happened
you know what I'm saying so um yeah so
yeah yeah man I'd like to apply well I
have a question what was your guys's
thoughts when you went to each other's
podcasts videos was it oh yeah also
you're an elder I keep forgetting bring
you the certificate oh really
yeah you [ __ ] guest hosted the show
oh yeah pin for you dude is really cool
you really uh-huh oh it's cool man thank
you dude it was an honor man it was it
was definitely scary yep like a you live
in like a gated community
first of all and the guy gave me a gang
gang whenever I rolled through no he
didn't god no Wyatt guy he was white guy
look very basic nice guy I don't even
know that he I have some video of him
excess secretly his videos videoing some
of the moments so cuz I don't know
what's gonna happen so I got up there
then and like yeah it was crazy somebody
was yeah there was like I think Magic
Johnson was good jogging in the
neighborhood like it was very intense
was sheep I don't that people some
people like I think it was Scotland was
like in the distance like it was very
are areas that are technically Scotland
in might yet there was a lot of
endangered species that's all that I had
nobody's seen in a long time actually
you know like oh you know they're
looking for you you know I told some of
the animals somebody said somebody said
to me once hey do you I could ask you do
you really rent your dogs yeah and I
said what do you think and they said no
and I said why are you asking this
question and they said that's how that
conversation went yeah man I gotta
listen to your podcast this more often
you don't have any it's kind of yes but
it's good there's no guess but yeah man
people I mean a lot of people who have
you know are concerned about their
health and safety let's I liked I liked
doing the [ __ ] you did yeah [ __ ]
thanks yeah it was really fun yeah I
thought was really fun and it was good
for us I think that like you know oh
it's shocked people even my mom was like
what is happening son dude Mike are you
getting enough Sun that's what she said
ha ha ha like you're strangely tan yeah
look like a guy that should be much
whiter than you are and you and you know
that and you know yeah yeah boy yeah
what's the deal do are you outside a lot
huh are you yeah um you know uh part of
my family's room Nicaragua bro and it's
not a racial sir yeah my father
Nicaragua what yeah Nicaragua brah where
my Nick gar is that huh well a little
too close okay yeah and hopefully the
audio was clear on that yeah it was a
sea in there
okay good yeah dude it was scary
actually I got there and I was like oh
how does he it felt different to me I
felt it was hard I felt like it was fun
but it was hard I wish I'd prepared a
lot of people loved it ah I mean I guess
I thought I didn't really prepare either
but but sometimes like them like what
some of the most fun I had was taking
the calls you know you just like this
[ __ ] was hilarious those guys the
[ __ ] guys like your listeners bro
yeah they're like you know how you know
what your listeners are like some of
them not all of them
uh-huh but some of their lists like you
know oh I know they're listening get
ready for this because this is what jar
okay so you are you know you know have
you ever seen Total Recall the first one
or where the guy's like they're tit did
the guy coming out of the side yes your
listeners are that guy and you're the
guy oh yeah
yeah your listeners are like the guy
coming at you and they're just like when
they call them quanta or whatever the
[ __ ] it is with it what is it what the
[ __ ] phone
that's your listener those were some of
your listeners bro what the [ __ ] can I
call that guy
somebody Q who knows it's not in the new
one though with oh my god dude you live
in such a weird space let's get one more
for mr. Chris D'Elia kappa yet here we
go hey guys it's khayrat from rhode
island my question for Chris is do you
think you could grow a mullet equally as
great or better than Theo's and if you
could would you consider going on a
mullet boys tour together thanks guys
that's a good question I'm a little boy
that question I like the guys energy he
did he was confident with me yeah yeah
at first I was like I'll [ __ ] this but
think it's very confident a nice young
man - should have again thought about
his hair a little bit before he [ __ ]
cent it or didn't have any plans yeah no
plans also it has a shirt on backwards
no no it's not backwards it's an outlet
NHL shirt that's a logo goes there bro
that's crazy
but yeah so anyway looks like a good he
will say this his eyebrows look like
they're a little scared of each other
yeah but they're trying to get you know
they lured you're trying to get over his
ears yeah but they're gonna figure it
out
and also I'm just loving this fan here
is no no no this is why you gotta
[ __ ] you gotta tell the fans how it
is bro
yeah how it is
oh you gotta man the great guys are
young guys we don't know that dude this
guy's everybody kill people you don't
know that
okay cuz we literally be literally could
be his [ __ ] somebody behind him just
like literally sure you think of murder
has ever stopped a murderer to watch one
of our podcasts yeah yeah one of ours
yes a hundred percent
you think there's somebody laying dead
somewhere with our podcast just playing
in the back I think somebody's been
killed to our Kazekage wallet was on
like a American Psycho instead of he was
in the news my dress cut just [ __ ]
over and over again stabbed and I'm in
the back just being like you know let's
go to [ __ ] miss connection yeah
and then they died and then like [ __ ]
the after my podcast is like [ __ ] god
save America it's another Logan Paul
talking to a stripper yeah um that's a
good question man well we were even lost
about Molly
I almost say this I don't think I could
pull them all it off like you no way
yeah yeah you've got the right look for
it but also I would I wouldn't I like it
I like a mullet yeah yeah I would like
to do maybe like a mohawk at some point
oh very cool but I think I got [ __ ]
maybe I got a weird head I don't even
know I haven't seen my head dude that's
a risky move and what's in my head would
you ever go buzz cut that's it and never
seen my head oh I'd never seen my head I
wouldn't I ever do a buzz comments way
scare you gotta be a psychopath
my head's like Braveheart I've never
seen it yeah never seen it saw once so
I'll be honest would never see him again
Wow yep well you guys can listen to
congratulations pod I got my podcast
congratulations love your podcast love
this past weekend yeah thanks for being
here man yeah that was one of the
craziest things ever I'm watching when
you walked on to the screen and our
podcast on this podcast I was like holy
Sh it's like seeing your teacher at the
supermarket you're like what are you
doing
yeah yep actually mr. Robertson's in
Ralph's no way [ __ ] you like oh yeah you
got a real life I forgot you think of
your teachers just like if we're gonna
at the end of the class period like okay
and then they just buy and then close
the door and they just [ __ ] get in a
bed like an apple next one but they
don't bro they go [ __ ] to the
supermarket and [ __ ] they got families
yeah you see what's in their cart you're
like what weird tuna fish
macaroni bro yeah you're nuts where's
your wife
that was always a scarce you realize
they don't have a wife person with their
wife is their wife is always another
teacher in in like the different school
right that's mrs. app Roberts is in
[ __ ] Flint Ridge or some [ __ ] yeah
things have really changed out here um
Chris Thalia thanks for coming by man
thank you man I had a [ __ ] blast I
love coming back I've been wanting to
come back so I'm happy really yeah I'm
sorry that you did man will you ever
have other guests besides your brother
on your podcast I don't know I only have
my brother one time but if I do yeah
you're first in line man yeah and I got
him the YouTube live chat on that it was
fun oh you did
ripping him oh I think I remember that
yeah so funny I just called him Salvador
Dali like 30 but that was pretty cool
though was it fun having your brother on
yeah he's dope yeah it's cool he's gonna
start a podcast he actually started it
he's just banking the episodes and
release him he's got his park is gonna
be [ __ ] awesome I really I don't know
what if you would want me to talk about
it or not but it's [ __ ] awesome he's
got awesome guests hmm yeah it's cool I
can't wait to [ __ ] hear have there
been um it has anybody reached out yet
about you being a superhero like from I
know this is gonna happen for you like I
believe like I'm not joking about that
like I know that you're going to be like
some sort of a superhero I don't know
what though the world will be in or if
it you could be I mean you can even
probably create your own universe of
superheroes I think that would be very
cool yeah I would love to do that
because you could do that I ya know I
haven't been reached out for any
superhero yeah but Zachary Levi DN the
other day so we're getting close
it's all it takes man yeah all it takes
bro
alright crystal yeah thank you so much
for being here man thank you
[Music]
little time for me to set that parking
brake
Oh
[Music]